- As my stakeout for a
young vandal continued,
I was starting to get frustrated.
I had been monitoring the
poster for over four hours,
and no one had defaced it.
For a moment, I thought
this wasn't going to work.
But I was quickly proven wrong.
Oh, he's taking the pen.
Oh my God, he's actually doing it.
On camera.
Let's go, let's go.
Hey man.
- Hey.
- Hey, how's it going?
- It's going.
- Cool, what are you doing there?
Oh, that's so funny, you drew a (bleep).
- [Man] Yeah.
- Yeah, that's really funny.
We're doing a show
about teens, cool teens,
called Teen Street.
Is it cool if we ask you a
few questions for the show?
- Sure, no problem.
- All right, cool, that's really funny.
That's mega funny.
- Yeah, it is.
- [Nathan] This teen was no good,
and his parents needed
to know what he did.
So to earn his trust, I told him
we wanted to make an entire
Teen Street episode about him.
So he spent the rest of his afternoon
shooting segments for a fake show.
- What up, I'm Kyle, 19 years
old, and this is Teen Street.
If you don't like it, (bleep) you.
I do whatever the I want and
I can do whatever I want.
The thing I'm most proud of is
I make a (bleep) load of money.
No regrets.
(cheering)
- Listen to that.
- Bam.
Yeah, I skated for six years,
played the drums for six years,
and in more time, Brazilian jiu jitsu.
You have to love your mom.
If you don't, go (bleep) yourself.
- This show is about the
coolest teens in town.
- [Both] Teen Street, bitches.
- First tattoo when I was 13.
This is the only girl that
never complains to me.
Alright, so now I'm gonna
show you where I live.
Let's do this.
- [Nathan] For the final
part of the segment,
I said we had to do a tour of his house.
He didn't know it, but
he was leading me right
to his parents, and I was going to
tell them what he did to my poster.
- What up, this is my pad.
This is where I spend
my time making trouble.
I'm going to show you a tour real quick.
- So who's this lovely lady?
- [Kyle] Oh, well this is my mom, Sherry.
- Awesome, man.
- [Sherry] Nice to meet you.
- Best teens have moms.
- Right?
- Yeah.
Alright, but we need to
stop laughing for a moment,
because we have to sit down.
I have something to talk about.
- Okay.
- He's drawn two penises right there,
and you can see I'm holding them as if
I'm masturbating these two men.
(laughing)
You're laughing.
- [Sherry] I don't--
- [Nathan] Is that funny to you?
- No, this is not funny.
- The penises, do you like
that, being held like that?
(laughing)
So this is, okay.
So this is funny to you.
- That's not funny.